what's going on guys this is robin as a
preface this might be a spoiler i'm not
entirely sure i have not seen morbius
yet and in fact we actually hired a guy
on to handle half the press junkets so
that i'm not just overwhelmed and he saw
morbius so i have no idea what's in the
film uh however one of you all sent me
an email where you were basically
talking about an interview that was done
with the director of morbius with
espinoza kind of talking about
the grand scheme of things right so this
is where it might be a little bit
spoilery but we did a video previously
where we talked about toby maguire and
tom holland and andrew garfield that
this was basically a thing where i kind
of argued that they were essentially
spider totems or at least some variation
of the spider totems that exist in in
the marvel cinematic universe and really
the marvel cinematic multiverse now
and the director had come out and
seemingly confirmed that so here's what
he had to say
in talking about the multiverse he said
you have a world where you have the same
characters and it's all of the
characters but they are slightly
different so in almost all universes you
have spider-man or fantastic four team
or tony stark or a morbius but they will
be different in tone that's not quite
the way the marvel cinematic universe
approaches the idea but they're
remaining to the same core truth then
you have the second kind of legend that
which is about the totem which is that
in all universes there is a spider totem
which means that in all universes there
has to be a spider-man or a spider woman
now i don't know exactly what this means
outside of the totems the the ongoing
theory based on that interview that's
circulating around out there is that the
spider-man that we see in the morbius
film is not a spider-man we've seen
before it's not tom holland it's not
andrew garfield and it's not tobey
maguire that it's a fourth live-action
spider-man and things are just kind of
unfolding there right that in effect uh
morbius is a movie that's part of the
multiverse it has all the characters
that we know but it's a different
universe version of those characters so
it's kind of interesting right and it
kind of makes sense to a degree that
when you look at michael keaton as the
vulture as adrian toombs if it really is
just an alternate reality version of
these characters you then that really
explains how it is that you can have
michael keaton playing adrian tombs in a
morbius universe that's not in the same
universe as the tomahaw and spiderman
films now having said that the totems is
really the more interesting thing
because as we said in that previous
video and as we're going to say here the
totems would really build up to
something bigger especially the idea of
null more so than that if they wanted to
do the inheritors if they wanted to
bring in those different iterations of
the villains that basically travel
around and consume anybody related to
the totemic aspect of superpowers more
so than that because of the fact that
the totems are basically based on
animals now you also get to invoke black
panther so for those of you guys who
never saw that previous video what it
means when we talk about totems is we're
essentially saying superheroes whose
powers are based off animals so like
black panther right he inherited the
powers of the panther god or panther
goddess past and then in turn operates
as the panther god's avatar on earth but
he's modeled after the black panther
black panther is an animal therefore he
is the earthly avatar of the black
panther totem with spider-man which is
really where a bulk of the totemic
discussion comes from that peter got his
powers from a radioactive spider and as
a result of that he represents the
spider on the animal kingdom totem of
different animals right that kind of a
thing the reason why spider-man is
really the bulk of the discussion when
it comes to totems is because that's
where it originated from and then based
on that that's where the inheritors were
always tracking down spiders there was a
point where merlin who is one of the
inheritors had actually tracked down
black panther and tried to kill him
didn't work and that ultimately he was
defeated
but the important thing here is that uh
it brings in a much bigger picture more
so than that it really unites everything
in a very elegant in a very simple way
one of the big questions that's really
been asked here recently is that if
we're talking about like spider-man into
the spider-verse and we're talking about
spider-man beyond spider-verse then you
look at spider-man no way home and
you've got tom toby and andrew who are
all teaming up like this can't just be a
coincidence it can't just be a thing
where like sony and marvel sat down and
said you know what would be cool having
a whole bunch of different movies where
different versions of spider-man team up
that leads to nothing right like nobody
would would be a fan of that right it
would make sense they're building up to
something bigger this is kind of the
spider-man equivalent of like an
infinity stone appearing in this movie
then like an infinity stone appearing in
that movie captain america shield having
a kind of cameo in an iron man movie
right just small little tidbits here and
there that are all going to combine into
a greater whole we already know based
off spider-man beyond spider-verse we're
going to get miguel o'hara and
presumably spider-punk and maybe a
couple other versions of spider-man by
the way there's some amazing versions of
spider-man animal comics but then when
you combine in like tom toby and andrew
teaming up then you look at the events
of spider-man into the spider-verse it
makes perfect sense that what they're
building is a spider multiverse that
there is a big event that is somehow
going to unfold in some form or another
and it's going to lead to all these
different iterations of spider-man
teaming up the big question you have to
ask here is who's going to be the guy
when it comes to like the different
spider-man who's going to be the guy
because the one thing i would say is
whether or not you're a fan of toby or
tom or andrew really depends on what era
of spider-man you grew up in if you went
into the to the spider-man movies with
like nostalgia so you grew up with the
raimi films toby maguire is your guy
right if you are a guy who recently
joined the mcu with like iron man he
never really watched any comic book
movies before that then tom holland is
probably your guy and no one was a fan
of andrew garfield until we got to his
appearance in this movie and then
suddenly everybody who hated his movies
loves them now search me for why but the
important thing here is that it depends
on what area you're coming from in terms
of which spider-man you like the most so
it's not one of those things where like
on the surface it's obvious toby maguire
is like the spider-man guy he's like the
head honcho there's no guarantee it
would work out that way the bigger thing
though is that with the director coming
out and saying in every single one of
these universes that exists in the
marvel cinematic universe multiverse
there has to be a version of spider-man
now we come across a virtually endless
uh type of spider-man that can exist a
really good example of this is spiders
man literally a man made of spiders it's
weird it's kind of creepy i'm pretty
sure we covered him in spider-verse over
at comics explained but it's just one of
those different iterations that exist
out there there is also my personal
favorite who is superior spider-man i've
loved superior spider-man i can't wait
to see superior spider-man in the marvel
cinematic universe the beauty of this is
that if the morbius film really does
include a version of spider-man who's
just there and it's his own version of
spider-man that is not tied to any of
the other projects in movies that we've
seen before then this would largely
confirm what we already know which is at
this point we don't need the origin of a
spider-man in an alternate reality that
if he is in that film and if somewhere
along the line uh jared leto's michael
morbius faces off against that version
of spider-man
we don't really need to know the
specifics right we don't need to know
how that spider-man became spider-man it
could just kind of be left to us okay so
either uncle ben died or aunt may die
whatever it was he was probably bitten
by a radioactive spider and that was it
i mean they would probably give us how
he got his powers if for no other reason
than basic curiosity but like we don't
necessarily need a great big huge
hour-long segment to explain that
spider-man is spider-man you'd have to
leave planet earth to find someone who
doesn't know who he is so it's pretty
straightforward but this also gives us a
litany of possibilities right a really
good example of this is enigma for
spider-man that's a guy that we could
get now right those of you guys who
don't know what the who enigma force
spider-man is this is basically a
version of spider-man who got what was
basically the enigma force and they call
it that because nobody knows what the
hell it is it's just a really powerful
source of energy that bonds itself to a
person and when spider-man got that it
was actually during the uh during the
loki's storyline god what was the name
of that story
um
oh my god it's the one where loki
brought all the villains together to try
to defeat the heroes um acts of
vengeance right it's from the acts of
vengeance storyline where he basically
became captain universe and like that
was it right it didn't last too long and
the enigma force left him but there was
an alternate reality version of peter
where he never lost the enigma force and
he was ridiculously op until he was
killed by the inheritors right by like
solace of the inheritors dude absorbed
the entirety of his life energy and then
killed him it was crazy it was just
really really ridiculous moment but it
means you could see all kinds of
different things now the enigma force as
we're aware does not exist in the marvel
cinematic universe in the traditional
sense but it actually does the enigma
force is what i would say uh janet van
dyne had in ant-man right the enigma
force is the source of energy that
permeates the microverse the micro
versus the quantum realm in the marvel
cinematic universe that's literally what
it is just a microscopic universe and
like that's it right the enigma force
permeates all of that and it can bond
itself to a person and they can just go
forward from there so again you could
see all different kinds of possibilities
with these versions of spider-man in the
marvel cinematic universe i love that
this is basically confirmed right that
like in every single one of these
universes out there in the multiverse
there is a version of spider-man or
spider-woman right they are totems it's
inarguable now what role they play as
totems that's where things will start to
get interesting because it's one thing
to be a spider totem it's another to be
the scion or the other right or
something along those lines right the
bride in the case of some version of
spider woman out there maybe cindy moon
maybe spider gwen maybe somebody else
who knows but we won't really know until
the whole thing drops until they reveal
that to us but i'm just saying there's
great possibilities here and there's a
lot that can come out of this now again
i haven't seen morbius so i don't really
know exactly what it is he's referencing
if there's anything on the nose right if
there's a point where like there's a
post-credits scene with null or the
inheritors or anything along those lines
i have no clue right i'm going to go see
the movie in theaters just like
everybody else and i'm excited to see
the review on the film or to do the
review when the film comes out but
regardless uh these are the kind of
things that we're dealing with here
right so it's effectively confirmed by
the director and so at this point uh
your imagination is really the limit in
terms of what kind of spider-man
inspired women you could see so for
those of you guys who are familiar with
the marvel cinematic universe i know all
of you guys are right if you could pick
or you could have one variation of
spider-man right one variant of
spider-man what would it be and this
it's your imagination right so like
spider-man who became captain america
right so who basically received the
super soldier serum and then was bitten
by a radioactive spider later on a
version of spider-man who replaced iron
man so instead of tony stark bringing on
james rhodes is war machine it was peter
parker right like what kind of version
would you want to see right let your
imagination run wild in the comments
because i would absolutely love to see
what you all come up with but with that
being said we're going to bring this to
an end thank you all for watching and i
will catch you all later
peace